il faut que les autorités
acceptent la responsabilité qui est la
leur
ce en quoi je pense que les jeux
olympiques ne peuvent pas se dérouler à
paris il faut que des mesures soient
prises pour protéger les personnes en
fauteuil roulant
j'espère qu'il y aura des enseignements
tirés de cette triste soirée
le cas échéant de nombreuses vies seront
mises en danger s'il n'ya pas de
changement je conseille à tous les
supporters en fauteuil de ne pas se
rendre à des événements au stade de
france
pour conclure j'aimerais dire au
ministre de l'intérieur que il a humilié
les habitants de paris et il est la
honte du gouvernement
nous connaissons et nous aimons paris et
la france avec mon épouse mais monsieur
darmanin a menti et ça a ajouté à notre
douleur et à notre traumatisme je vous
demande donc monsieur darmanin de
retirer vos accusations sans fondement
et si vous avez la décence de le faire
alors j'espère aussi que vous aurez
la décence de démissionner
il y à 33 ans déjà les autorités ont
menti sur les événements qui se sont
déroulés à hillsborough et qui ont
conduit à la mort de 97 personnes les
agissements et le discours de monsieur
darmanin nous a rappelé cette époque
sombre et rien que pour ça il devrait
avoir honte j'aimerais remercier le
sénat français aujourd'hui monsieur
lafon et messieurs peu fait pour
la manière dont ils se sont comportés et
pour avoir organisé ces auditions
il faut avoir le courage de dire la
vérité
même au plus puissant j'aimerais vous
remercier d'avoir écouté la voix des
supporters handicapés
des supporters aveugle des supporters
jeunes des supporters en fauteuil
roulant aujourd'hui
le club de liverpool a connu les
mensonges depuis 33 ans donc
faire jaillir la vérité pour nous
aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement important
pour moi pour duo et pour bien d'autres
c'est beaucoup plus important que vous
ne pouvez l'imaginer
pour nous ça a une importance vitale
j'aimerais aussi remercier les
journalistes français et les médias
français qui se sont rendus à liverpool
pour faire éclater la vérité c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
réconfortant pour nous mais tant que la
vérité n'est pas
révélée au grand jour nous ne serons
jamais jamais satisfait vous ne
marcherez jamais seul comme le veut la
devise de notre club merde
[Musique]